vor einiger Zeit habe ich diese E-Mail
bekommen hallo Thomas und Team ich bin
David 17 Jahre alt und komme aus
Freiburg ich komme direkt zum Punkt und
zwar habe ich mir vor ca einem Jahr beim
Arbeiten in der Werkstatt den kleinen
Finger abgesägt ich habe gesehen dass es
fertige Vorlagen zum 3D drucken einer
fingerprothese gibt ich habe schon oft
versucht das Ganze selbst zu machen bin
allerdings gescheitert da ich weder
Erfahrung mit dem 3D Druck noch einen
Druck hab und dann kam er auf folgende
Idee der Bau einer 3D gedruckten
fingerprothese wäre doch ein sehr
interessantes Projekt habe ich mir
gedacht und vorgestellt dass du mir
helfen könntest und hatte recht es ist
ein sehr interessantes Projekt und ich
helfe natürlich auch gern deswegen
machen wir jetzt genau das und zwar
nicht nur mit einem normalen Finger
sondern auch Aufsätze die einiges mehr
können als so ein normaler Finger das
kann dieses Video wird unterstützt von
opra mehr dazu später wie bist Du drauf
gekommen auf die Idee also wie gesagt
ich hatte eben diese diesen Unfall so
weiter und ich guck deine Videos
tatsächlich schon ein bisschen habe ich
immer wahnsinnig auch inspiriert ich
mache selber auch viel Zeug so bei mir
in meiner Werkstatt gerade deswegen habe
ich das hier ja oh
willst du willst du drüber reden wie das
passiert ist ja natürlich das habe ich
so oft erzählt das ist wirklich egal
also ksel gestanden am Boden ich habe
schnell schnell gemacht diese kapsäige
wenn ihr wisst was es ist
runtergezogen plötzlich ja das hat halt
laut geknallt hab das gar nicht gemerkt
plötzlich merke ich meine linke Hand die
ist so leicht also die wiegt weniger
tatsächlich und dann gucke ich da halt
hin und du hast daran gemerkt dass es
leichter ist ja wow das ist super
gruselig also sorry aber das das uh
krass und dann ja dann es hat doch nicht
viel geblutet nur so wie Nasenbluten
oder so bin damit eigentlich voll klar
gekommen in dem Moment ich bin ich groß
ausgerastet oder so und wollte dann den
erstmal suchen erfolglos gesucht dann
meine Eltern Geschwister kamen dazu
haben dann geholfen suchen wir haben den
ganzen die ganze Werkstatt auseinander
genommen Alter das B auf gekommen sind
dass dieser Finger in die Absauganlage
von der sä reesaugt W mein Gott du
erzählst das auf jeden Fall sehr
humorvoll ja es war nicht so humorvoll
in dem Moment aber oh krass er ist
Respekt dass du damit so locker umgehen
kannst heftig zwei Jahre hat's gedauert
bis ich jetzt an dem Punkt bin und da
habe ich dieses Video gesehen von
corridor Crew und dort hat eben auch
jemand für ein Freund der hat genau wie
ich linke Hand kleiner Finger fehlt dem
Halt und dann hat er da auf thingywse
dieses Modell gefunden wo Nick heißt er
glaube ich Programm anbietet wo man
direkt seine fertige Prothese sich
erstellen lassen kann und so weiter und
dort kann man alles einstellen also
Wandstärke dieses Modell breite Länge
Höhe alles also der Typ der das
entwickelt hat hat wirklich sich ultra
Gedanken gemacht und ich habe hier auch
schon so mit einem Kollege eben der ein
3D Drucker hat mal so ein paar
pestpieces gemacht das funktioniert ganz
grob aber wie man sieht in gewissen
Bewegung
irgendwann ja ja jetzt habe ich mir
gedacht warum hole ich mir nicht
professionelle ja professionell ist das
jetzt nicht aber wir geben auf jeden
Fall uns Bestes und wenn es cool ist
dann wäre das eine coole Sache ja ja
geil wir machen das so hier haben wir
das
Paket fingerprothesis drauf und das ma
auf wir haben David ja so eine
Abdruckmasse geschickt und da sollte er
quasi jetzt uns se Abdruck geschickt
haben bin jetzt gespannt
sein hol mal alles
raus okay ja hier ist ein Abdruck cool
verrückt das muss ja quasi dann hier
sein
quasi und dann noch mal das gleiche ich
glaub mehrere gemacht damit wir den
besten uns aussuchen
können also er hier in der Mitte ist
definitiv der beste der beste Abdruck
also nehmen wir einfach mal den ich habe
jetzt hier so eine kleine Gussform
vorbereitet in den Plastikbecher damit
da nichts rausläuft so jetzt muss da
erstmal das Silikon angemischt werden
das Verhälnis ist 1 z50 also 5,5 g von
dem guten Zeug hier was auch immer das
ist silikonvernitzer gut R nicht so 5,5
exakt
das ist ein Loch drin schnell dann gieße
ich das er mal über das Loch
praktischerweise einfach da rein okay
das natürlich jetzt dumm egal geben
einfach
rein und das Zeug braucht jetzt erstmal
eine Weile um auszuhärten Silikon ist
mittlerweile fest
ja crazy
crazy Material wirklich krass so ich
schne das mal den Becher auf so wie
machen wir das weiter erst Schraube hier
wegnehmen die ist ein reingefallen und
jetzt kann man das hier um das Tape rum
einf mal easy abziehen das ist ziemlich
cool also ja das meist jetzt schon mal
weg glaube ich von draußen so und darin
zum Vorschein kommt das hier und das
müssen wir jetzt irgendwie wegkriegen
und das ist schon nicht so ganz so
leicht weil das an Silikon ganz gut dran
klebt das wird tricky auf jeden Fall das
löst sich jetzt auch nicht so richtig
davon weg ne ist einfach eins damit
geworden ich habe das er no ein zweites
Mal gemacht diesm ein bisschen
erfolgreicher das heißt ich habe jetzt
den Teil hier bekommen das was ich
wollte kann hier quasi jetzt Maß nehmen
es ist ein bisschen was noch abgebrochen
vom Silikon aber ja ich denke für die
Maße passt und Z anier pas auch ich find
es unfassbar krass wie viele Details man
h sieht man sieht einfach jede einzelne
Falte der Haut das schon sehr sehr krass
das ist schon bisschen gruselig david
hatte ja davon gesprochen dass es hier
sowas gibt von Nick der hat ja auf
thingyw quasi eine fingerprothese zur
Verfügung gestellt die man einfach auch
an seinen eigenen Finger anpassen kann
dann also muss man quasi irgendwelche
Werte eingeben und so weiter und so fort
wir werden später auf jeden Fall noch
mal komplett eigene wilde Aufsätze für
alses möglich für Schrauben für
vielleicht ein Kugelschreiber und so
weiter und so fort aber davor würde ich
auf jeden Fall einfach mal das probieren
was der Nick hier zur Verfügung gestellt
hat und dafür nehmen wir jetzt quasi
hier von unsere Maße und geben die D mal
rein und schauen was dai rauskommt und
zwar gibt's ja auch eine PDF die hab
genau erklärt was man da jetzt wo genau
messen muss einmal den Umfang vom Finger
dafür erst ein bisschen Tape drauf hier
ist jetzt einmal Klebeband drum rum
gewickelt das nehme ich jetzt ab Schneid
einmal durch und mess es einfach mit dem
Lineal kommt jetzt ein bisschen Matte
wir wollen nämlich Durchmesser und
kommen auf Wert von 21,33 und das
Schreiben wir jetzt hier rein 21,33 die
Bauteile die für die mechanische
Funktion verantwortlich sind haben wir
dann für den Prototyp aus Knall pinken
und stabilen filament gedruckt die
Fingerkuppe und die undock Höse haben
wir für das realistische Gefühl und für
mehr Grip aus flexiblem gummiartigem TPU
gedruckt die sind jetzt hier schon
fertig aufgeteilt einmal in Teile aus
Gummi und einmal hier Teile die aus
festen Stoff sind ja der nicht flexibel
ist und die sind richtig hübsch geworden
genau dann gibt's noch mal einmal das
aus Gummi das jetzt hier auch schon
fertig gedruckt hat manu hat dafür das
ist übrigens Manu der hat dafür
dieses TPU ja also dieses gummiilament
hier aufgespannt an dem Besen einfach
weil das andere filament halt hier drin
ist in so einem filamentwechsler ist
voll wild das heiß man kann hier einfach
eine Soft einstellen welches DAV man
haben will und das wird dann automatisch
da weitergeleitet nur hier geht das halt
nicht dass man da Zeug aus Gummi rein
macht weil das so flexibel ist und das
kann man nicht so richtig schieben J auf
jeden Fall gehen wir jetzt da
rein und das ist immer sehr sehr
schwierig zu drucken aber schaut jetzt
aus W es ganz gut geworden ja also TPU
ist immer berühmt berüchtig dafür dass
es schwierig ist zu drucken weil daimmer
so Fäden davon wegstehen aber ist auf
jeden Fall gut genug geworden wir bauen
das jetzt mal zusammen okay also als
erstes kann man das Zusammenstecken das
schon sehr sehr geiler Mechanismus da
kommt jetzt quasi noch so ein Bolzen
rein muss ich erstm die richtige Länge
jetzt
[Musik]
markieren und dann auch noch
zusägen ich schleif das noch ein
bisschen aus damit das ein bisschen
lockerer drin sitzt wenn ihr euch das
übrigens sel bauen wollt oder
irgendjemanden kennt für den ihr das
bauen wollt habe ich das natürlich in
der wieobeschreibung mal verlinkt von
dem guten Nick der das hier alles Design
hat dann kommt der Bolzen hier rein da
brauch ich aber echt ein Hammer
wieder jetzt bewegt sich
gut so geht wie geschmiert übel cooler
Mechanismus ich habe jetzt noch ein paar
kleine Schräubchen reingemacht und mit
den Schräubchen werden jetzt eben diese
Schnüre befestigt und die ziehe ich
jetzt rein ich ma mal erstmal den Gummi
glaube ich schieb einfach rein boah ist
das VI Geran ne so jetzt kommt er hier
raus jetzt kann ich den Gummi hier mit
einer Schraube vorne einspannen also
habe ich jetzt die Gummis durchgezogen
das ist einmal einer hier und einmal
einer oben lang zwei verschiedene die
sorgen jetzt dafür dass man das hier
biegen kann und dass es wieder
zurückspringt und dass man dieses Gelenk
und dieses Gelenk separat streng
einstellen kann und zwar indem man halt
am Gummi anzieht und dann die Schraube
ja mal bisschen fester stellt so hier
ist die Angelschnur reingezogen und
damit kann man jetzt quasi hinten
anziehen und dann bewegt sich der Finger
ich hab es auch eingestellt wie gesagt
über diese Gummis
dass sich beide gleichzeitig bewegen
fehl noch die Fingerspitze komm jetzt
vorne quasi die fingerkappe drauf oh das
richtig gut funktioniert geil und hinten
kommt quasi diese Aufnahme drauf also
das Teil womit man es dann an der Hand
befestigt mach man das so drauf wenn ich
jetzt hierinten anziehe dann bewegt sich
der Finger super cool also ich fin
wirklich super cool der biegemchanismus
kannich n bisschen nacharmen ne aber der
funktioniert so dass man hier Armband
hat da kommt dann hier so ein Steg rein
und hier kommt die Schnur rein die wird
dann später noch festgeknotet ich
kannürlich nur bisschen nacharm aber da
W das später hier drauf stecken und wenn
er das dann
bewegt dann sollte er sich da so
reinbeugen ich wür sagen das stellen wir
dann später zusammen mit ihm ein wir
machen jetzt aber weiter weil das ist zw
hoffentlich super nützlich für David er
hat sich noch ein paar extra Sachen
gewünscht und die machen wir jetzt hast
du denn irgendwelche Wünsche wünsche ich
glaub diese Spitze da kann man am Ende
alles dran bauen was man will also
Schraubenzieher sehr praktisch K
wirklich
hinkriegen Stift stimmt auch gute Idee
ja ja dann haben wir do schon mal was
den haben wir mit so einem biitthalter
umgesetzt wo später noch ein Magnet
reinkommen wird den stiftaufsatz seeht
ihr hier gerade auch und da kommt auch
noch etwas Wildes dazu aber dazu später
mehr den Finger haben wir übrigens noch
mal neu gedruckt diesmal komplett in
schwarz weil sich David diese Farbe
gewünscht hat das sind jetzt die
Aufsätze die man hier einfach so auf den
Finger draufleiden kann bzw das ist ja
quasi der normale Fingerspitze die
steckt man h ein drauf dieser Gummi und
dann funktioniert das gut dann kann man
die abmachen wir fangen mal mit dem
ersten an das ist einfach der
stiftaufsatz ja easy steckt einfach hier
ein Stift Rein oder kann man hier was
kürzeres nehmen Zack und dann kann man
hier quasi jetzt einfach an diesen
Finger ein Bleistift drauf machen und
hat dann quasi am Fingern ein Bleistift
und ich weiß nicht ob man damit
schreiben kann ich glaube aber dass man
wenn man in der Werkstatt ist einfach
super gut ir die Sachen markieren kann
also mir z.B geht das super oft so dass
ich irgendwie sag okay ne ich brauche
jetzt hier weiß ich nicht 40 cm und will
mir das Markieren aber ich finde kein
Stift ohne Witz passiert mir ständig ich
glaube das wäre sehr sinnvoll wenn da
einfach ein Stift dran ist glaub gesagt
nicht dass man damit schön schreiben
kann klein Finger aber ne wenn das jetzt
so dran ist und ich mir vorstelle dass
man hier mit dem kleinen Finger einfach
ein Strich dran macht so hier bei 40
dann denke ich dass es gut gehen sollte
dann kann man hier einfach an die Säge
gehen und zack sägt das Ding hier genau
ab der zweite ist ebenfalls auch was für
die Werkstatt wir haben erfahren dass
DAV auch gerne eine Werkstatt ist genau
der zweite Aufsatz ist eben für Bits z.B
hier eine Fernbedienung da muss man ja
manchmal Batterien auswechseln z.B so
und das jetzt ein Schraubenzieher mit
einem bit Halter da wo man jetzt quasi
kreuzstütz rein maachchen kann ein Imbus
also ihr kennt das mit Sicherheit und
schraubendrehermäßig hatte sich David
auch was gewünscht und das haben wir
jetzt so umgesetzt dass wir in diesem
Aufsatz der übrigens ähnlich ist wie der
vom Stift nur ein bisschen kleiner genau
dass hier ein B rein pasasst aber wir
machen das jetzt noch fancy weil da muss
ein Magnet rein mach Sekundenkleber
drauf und drückt das hier rein und damit
hält jetzt erstens der bit da besser
drin ja und das snppt hier rein aber vor
allem was ich fast noch wichtiger finde
ist dass einfach halt Schrauben jetzt
dran halten und nicht im irgendwie
wegfliegen also das ist auf jeden Fall
super praktisch ne dass jetzt die
Schraube dran hält und auch den Aufsatz
kann man ein drauf machen und hat dann
quasi an dem Finger direkt ja was zum
schrauben wir haben gerade ein Prototyp
gebaut von dem Messer am Finger einfach
mal um zu testen ob das funktioniert AUA
ja das ist gefährlich ich die schutzbr
noch an genau das funktioniert man kann
dit so Pakete öffnen man kann D mit
Papier aufschneiden man kann D mit Brief
öffnen das ist super geil und ich glaube
das wir sich durchsetzen irgendwie muss
natürlich noch sicher an diesem Finger
hier befestigt werden können und da
überlegen wir uns jetzt mal Mechanismus
genau also das ist jetzt quasi Aussatz
für Finger und hier soll dann die Klinge
so seitlich drauf geslidet werden können
so dann muss es noch ein bisschen
abgerundet werden hier vorne an der
Fingerspitze glaub so ist es ganz
gut so jetzt aus dem 3D Drucker erstes
machen wir die einschmelzmutter ich
finde die Dinger so genial Pack mir die
mal auf meinen lötkolb hier drauf und
dann kann man das hier drauf stecken
dieerweise klappt das jetzt sogar und
dann gleitet der da einfach rein und
jetzt der Trick also ich hoffe das
funktioniert jetzt ich schraube jetzt
hier die Schraube rein dann lege ich
hier die Klinge rein und lad dann durch
und damit die halt eben nicht slidet ne
man will ja nlich schneiden können ohne
dass sie einfach durchrutscht schraubt
man jetzt diese Schraube ein Fest dann
rutscht das nicht mehr durch aber dann
ist auf bomben fest und jetzt ist das
ein Aufsatz der idealerweise auch de
Finger drauf kann und idealerweise kann
man den auch noch jederzeit einfach
wieder zurückfahren und dann einach
durch anderen Aufsatz aus auf de Finger
drauf ist und der Finger ist jetzt
aktuell normal kann normal benutzt
werden das Ding da das tut ja natürlich
auch nichts weh ne also das ist extra so
dass es halt nach links außen gezeigt
wird und ist auch nicht scharf und dann
erst wenn man es braucht ma man hier
locker schiebt weiter raus macht hier
wieder fest hat man Razer Blade und kann
dann damit idealerweise auch ein Paket
schneiden ja ich glaube dass David das
cool finden wird also erstmal herzlich
willkommen David sehr cool dass du es
einrichten konntest ich hoffe dass es
irgendwas hilft und ich hoffe das
funktioniert ich Deck das mal
auf ich würde sagen wir fangen an mit
dem ganz normalen fingeraufsatz da geht
e darum ob der überhaupt passt ist schon
eigentlich gar nicht so schlecht ich
glaub die Spitzen gerade drücken noch
bisschen
raus
mal oh ja sieht gut aus ja das heiß du
brauchst jetzt ein Armband
okay der ist
weg krass das krass das ist sehr krass
ja lange nicht gemacht
ne
t mus man noch bisschen üben ne bisschen
lernen ab das ist schon krass
so
boah das sieht unfassbar cool aus ne
ja man hat halt kein Gespür damit ne ja
das ist das weirde aber muss halt gut
hingucken was man macht man muss auf
jeden Fall noch ein bisschen was
ausbesser aber ich finde das schon sehr
krass sehr cool ja nimmer einfach
irgendwie so ein Objekt keine Ahnung am
besten n mit den beiden ja das ist schon
ziemlich cool das ist nice ich kann auch
gut drücken also meine Hand ist da nicht
dran gewöhnt mir sieht bisschen aber wie
nützlich denkst du ist das im allag das
wir sich zeigen ne also ich bin jetzt
halt natürlich sehr lange dran gewöhnt
ohne und habe mich Hal deprechend
angepasst so dass ich jetzt eigentlich
quasi drauf verzichten kann natürlich
auf den Finger aber so ist es natürlich
schon also das super krass aus gan sieht
super krass aus wir haben jetzt ein paar
Sachen gemacht ne weil du hattest ja ein
paar extra Wünsche so jetzt probieren
wir mal den
ble dran ob einfach eine Markierung die
muss jetzt nicht krass sein die muss
halt mal mehr oder weniger natürlich ja
muss es halt sehen genau da sein wo sie
hin soll und man muss es sehen
genau ja ja ganz präzise ist n nicht ich
wür sagen wir probieren das nächste D
hast h noch ein radiiergummi und jetzt
die Frage ob man realistisch damit
radieren
kann ja okay umständlich es wird eine
Weile dauern aber do länger also
irgendwann wird's klappen ne so geht's
so geht's weil das könnte jetzt
tatsächlich nützig sein also ist noch
ein bisschen zu lang aber du kannst es
ja eigentlich so auch normal als Finger
benutzen ja ich kann trotzdem noch was
greifen so genau nur dass du zusätzlich
einfach immer ein Rast das nächste ist
ein biitalter und da weiß ich jetzt
nicht genau wie das funktionieren wird
das habe ich mir auch bisschen
nützlicher vorgestellt glaube ich als es
wirklich ist nicht die Hand denkst du
also das Problem was ich Hal sehe ist
dass man jetzt nicht ohne weiteres da
einen richtigen Motor reinkriegt Motor
ja also das wird schwierig denke ich mal
das habe ich mir eigentlich überlegt
dass man wirklich tatsächlich einen
Akkuschrauber quasi kleinen baut ja
glaub die schon locker ja ja geil jetzt
ist bisschen brutal das ist eine
Rasierklinge interessant und da musst
auf jeden Fall aufpassen wenn die
ausgefahren ist jetzt hast du erstmal
auch einen normalen Finger ne also jetzt
kannst Du quasi einfach auch Sachen
damit greifen alles mögliche hast aber
dann den Vorteil wenn du ein Paket
öffnen musst und so weiter und so fort
kannst du mit der anderen Hand hier
diese Schraube aufmachen schiebst den
hier raus machst die Schraube wieder zu
und jetzt wir passt bitte auf ja nicht
so viel Schwung die Frage ist kann man d
mit ein Paket aufmachen kannst du damit
genug Kraft
aufbringen sogar also ohne dass ich die
Hand zum Drücken benutze eigentlich das
macht gerade nur der Finger glaube ich
boah das ist
cool muss bisschen aufpassen wenn ich
durch bin dass ich nicht
Absch
boah stark sehr stark aber auch
gefährlich oder ja auf jeden Fall also
ab 18 ist ab 18 bist du jetzt geworden
oder ja gerade Glück gehabt noch ob ne
ne fingerbauen oder andere ausgefallene
Projekte die Recherche dafür findet
immer im Internet statt und da ist man
mit dem neuen opra Browser dem Sponsor
des heutigen Videos besonders schnell
unterwegs opra One ist die neueste
Version des opra Browsers der jetzt mit
einem brandneuen Design und praktischen
neuen Features kommt der Browser ist
jetzt völlig modular aufgebaut und
bietet einen integrierten Adblocker
sowie einen proxyervice der im Browser
alles verschlüsselt und eure IP
versteckt es gibt auch eine Sitebar mit
der Instagram WhatsApp und andere Chat
Apps immer griffbereit habt das
Besondere an opera One ist die nahlose
Integration von opras E igen KI area die
das Finden von Informationen ordentlich
erleichtert wenn euer Browser genauso
mit Tabs überladen ist wie das bei mir
norchmal der Fall ist und ja auch immer
wieder den Überblick über all die
offenen Tabs verliert helfen euch die
TAB Islands da werden eure Tabs
intelligent zu Inseln gruppiert um die
Übersicht zu behalten und alles
ordentlich zu sortieren opra One ist
komplett kostenlos ladet euch den
Browser einfach über den Link in der
Videobeschreibung runter und probiert
den selbst aus das war damit von diesem
Video ich hoffe ihr konnten David mit
unserem selbstgebauten Finger helfen und
ich werde euch auf jeden Fall auch auf
dem Laufenden halten ob er in Zukunft
noch mal eine Änderung braucht oder
welchen Aufsätze er vielleicht wirklich
benutzt oder welchen nicht und damit sei
ciao